this is a video that explains how to
destroy uh statues in peppa panic saga
statues are one of the three level
requirements that are currently in the
game
you have statues levels
match patterns levels and
levels that require you to complete
orders or collect peppers explode
peppers start pepper panics
i'm going to play level 32
it's a statues level
and you can see in the beginning that
all the statues
are fully intact
they're stage three that means they have
no damage to them
in some levels you'll have statues that
already have you know that'll look
smaller or broken up those are
take left hits to destroy when they're
fully intact like this they take three
so
the most common way to
damage a statue is to
explode a pepper
right next to it
and as you can see there that match
created a shock wave
and it actually hit
these statues
on the outside so they're now stage two
they're partially damaged
all right so there i made an explosion
that was directly touching the statue
and it caused damage to this one made it
a stage one and caused damage to this
one as well
so that's the easiest way
kind of the most effective way is
usually to shoot shock waves at them so
you make big matches like four pepper
matches
or five pepper matches in the shape of
an lrt
and those will send the shock wave
that'll hit the statue so if i match
these four red peppers here it's going
to remove this statue there it's also
going to make this green match
which uh
you'll see that it'll make a shock wave
as well
so we were able to remove that statue
and then the explosion that happened
afterwards
caused damage to a bunch of other
statues
so that's the basics of how you how you
damage a statue
you can see that
when this statue right here all the
tiles that are surrounding it will cause
damage so
even the ones that sit diagonally from
it
will
cause damage to the statue so if you if
you're wondering if you're gonna explode
a pepper and it's gonna
cause damage you can just basically look
around and see if um
you know if it's touching a square that
a statue is in
this is another example of a shock wave
this is a
l-shaped shock wave
that will hit this statue in this statue
and if there was one down here it would
hit that one as well
so you see that one was a stage one it's
completely removed
and you can also see the other benefit
of making shock waves is it starts other
things to happen on the board
and
this is one that's in the diagonal
position
that'll help you remove all the statues
faster than just a regular explosion
and this is our last one
we can make a t-shaped match here and
that'll knock that out and
remove all the statues
so that's the most basic type of
statue level the one where they're
easily accessible
and you just take them all out and then
complete the level
i'm going to show you one more example
of
a different kind of board where they're
not right
next to the play field
level 38 is the first kind of level like
this and there's there's quite a few
like this later on in the in the um
in the game
as you can see here these statues all
start out as stage twos they all have
some damage
but you can't get directly next to them
because there's a gap in the board
so the way you hit these are just by
making shock waves again so here's an
l-shaped match
that hits the one above and below
here's a t-shaped match it'll hit this
one in that one
so in order to get to these statues you
just one by one pick them off with these
big matches
and that's basically all you need to
know in later levels they'll be blocked
sometimes with um
other obstructions that aren't
introduced into the game until later and
you'll have to remove those first to get
to them
but basically they're
they're pretty simple
and
levels that have statues are some of the
most fun ones in the game i think
depending on how they're set up so
hopefully you understand this better and
you'll be able to get to them
if you have any questions leave a
comment be sure to subscribe to our
channel and check out our website
pepperpanictips.com
thanks